I don't ever give up I mean I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated you
have to keep going because the regret at
age 90 looking back on your life the
regret will be enormous most of the
founders that I have spent a lot of time
with they've gone on to be super
successful spent a very long time on
their idea when a lot of other people
would have given up
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it's up in my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message
never give up over to you Elon Musk
[Music]
four years after starting SpaceX rolled
out its first rocket an unmanned booster
called the Falcon one cleared the tower
but the first three test flights failed
to reach orbit we are hearing from the
launch control center that has been an
anomaly on the vehicle when you had that
third failure in a row did you think I
need to pack this in Devin why not I
don't ever give up I mean I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated it
turned out that the third failure was
caused by a two-second glitch in the
timing eight weeks later must bet the
company on another flight and this time
around everything worked perfect at that
fourth launch had to work that would
have been it we would have not had the
resources to the amount of fifth you
couldn't have gone out at that point yes
death would have been I think inevitable
because we did not have the resources to
to not to Perth launch this is a tricky
business trucking yeah yeah I wish it
wasn't so hard never give up is the best
and the worst advice you can ever give
an entrepreneur the trick is knowing how
to use it
if you love what you're doing if you
can't imagine life without this thing
that you're creating even if it's not
working out yet you're not getting the
results yet it's not where you want it
to be yet but you need to know you need
it's like this thing inside you that has
to come out you need to know it was
gonna work or not you could deal with
the failure but you can't deal with not
knowing if that's where you're at with
your idea with your business and you
have to keep going then you can't quit
then you have to find out because
otherwise it's gonna eat you up for the
rest of your life if that's where you're
at then you must find a way to keep
going even if that doesn't make any
sense even if you have to take on
part-time jobs even if you fail in front
of everybody
you have to keep going because the
regret at age 90 looking back on your
life
gret will be enormous that's how most
people live most people spend their
entire life regretting the things that
they didn't do go look at a retirement
home go talk to your grandparents and
great-grandparents and a lot of them
will be filled with regret I wish I did
this I wish I took my shot I wish I had
the courage I wish I had the bravery to
keep going if that's what you're worried
about then you must you must you must
you must you must you must not give up
and find the way to keep going that's
when it's good advice here's where it's
bad advice
I think people stay in things for too
long as well I think people stay in
their business for too long I think
people say in their relationships are
too long people stay with things because
it's comfortable because they know it
because they recognize it because it's
safe because it's helping generate some
money they stay in the wrong thing for
too long if you are in the wrong thing
then quit immediately I can't tell you
how many entrepreneurs I come across
who've had some level of success maybe
they're not crushing it but they've had
some level of success and then they
start to hate their business they start
to get bored of their business because
they never evolved because they grew as
a human being but their business didn't
grow alongside it and you keep getting
stuck doing the same thing over and over
and over again day in and day out and
you start to hate your business and you
feel like you have to stay in this
company because you should never give up
on it no quit get out of that thing
either change either adjust what you're
going to be doing they come up with a
new product come with the new service
make some tweaks or it's just so far
away from what you're interested in now
then quit try to sell the business if
there's a way out and if not just
abandon ship and go do something else
because this is the most important part
right here this part right now you will
never win doing work that you hate you
will never win you will never have
success you will never get the goals
that you want doing work that you hate
because the people who love doing that
work will always crush you you can have
the most talent the most skills the most
resources in the world but if you do not
love the work if you do not love the
process you will get crushed you will
get demolished by the people who love it
and you will never be
happy you will always be a junior
version of somebody else and so you have
to find the thing that you are so dead
in love with it's why finding your
passion doing the thing that you love is
consistently the number one most
important rule that comes up over and
over and over and over again in his
videos not because I'm sharing it
because all these people have had
success are sharing it and so you will
never win doing work that you hate if
you are loving the work that you're
doing if you have to find out if this is
gonna work or not then you can never
quit then you can never give up then you
have to see it through at least to know
you could deal with the failure but you
cannot deal with not knowing but if you
don't love what you're doing if you
don't love the thing anymore
then quit immediately move on adjust
find something else and know that
there's something great for you out
there and that's why never quit is the
best and the worst advice you can ever
give an entrepreneur now I've got some
special bonus clips you but before that
question of the day what do you think
about the advice never quit never give
up I'd love to hear from you leave it
down the comments below thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
[Music]
knowing when to quit and knowing when to
give up on something is there's no
perfect answer to that but it's really
challenging to even get that
approximately correct I think most
people give up on things way too early
so the mistake that most people make is
they try something it does not
immediately work you see this
particularly in young entrepreneurs it
does not immediately work after seven
weeks they say you know what I tried
this thing it's just not meant to be and
I have too many other projects and so
they immediately give up and you kind of
you know the satirical version of this
is people that are 23 and have started
14 startups because they give up on
everyone before had ever possibly
successful these things are really hard
they take a very long time there are a
lot of critics there are a lot of people
who say this thing sucks it's gonna fail
it's really stupid and then also there's
like what oh I see we call the trough of
sorrow where no one even bothers to say
it sucks because no one cares at all and
that is at least is demotivating most of
the founders that I have spent a lot of
time with that have gone on to be super
successful spent a very long time on
their idea when a lot of other people
would have given up and either people
said it sucks or people said nothing at
all and a framework that I have for when
to get up and when to keep working is it
should be an internal not an external
decision if people aren't using it or if
people are saying it's bad that alone is
not a reason to give up you want to pay
some attention to that they might be
right but I think the best entrepreneurs
I know they make an internal decision
about when to give up or when to keep
working on something it's basically when
you have run out of ideas and something
is not working then it's a good time to
stop it I honestly just don't think
about mistakes but let me see if I can
try I mean I I just like to if I make a
mistake I put it behind me and I just
move move move move forward but but but
you know and and you know yes I you know
I mean that there have been you know
music musical bands that I've missed
trying to sign like dust rates you know
they've been companies that have fallen
flat
their face like virgin Cola you know but
you know but you know that's just part
of that's just part of you know being an
entrepreneur you but you're going to
have these things happening all the time
so I don't really see them as mistake so
they're just you know they're just you
know if you're an entrepreneur you know
there's some things they're not gonna go
right something is they're gonna go
right brightness is the most demanding
mistress you're ever going to encounter
and I understand the advice that I'm
about to give you is not for everyone
most people should turn this off but if
you're gonna stick with me if you're
going to listen to what I have to say
it's because you want something
tremendous in your life you want to
stand out from everyone else you want to
do something more than other people
think as possible you literally want to
stand outside the norm and if that's the
case for you then understand that as
Albert Einstein said only one who
devotes himself to a cause with his
whole strength and soul can be a true
master for this reason mastery demands
all of a person if you want to get great
if you really want to make a skill set
your own if you want to be able to do
something and at the end of the day if
you want to transform the world if you
want to make grand changes if you want
to do all of that all the empty words
that people spout all the time let me
tell you the only thing that's going to
separate you from all the other
blowhards we're just talking words and
we'll never do anything is to give
yourself over completely to let that
obsession let that thing that you love
completely consume you and in that your
only chance to really become great lies
raise your standard Apple at the cool is
cool
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details